Ah quanto ti odio Anche io Sei
bruttissima oggi
tesoro che puffa chi cheo
l'ago Che brutto siete in diretta con
l'effetto bruttezza estrema Benvenuti
solita Stories siamo tornati a scuola e
oggi Noi siamo il team delle streghe
secchione Io sono Anita e io sono Gin no
siamo Charlotte e William vampiri
ovviamente popolari
selfie E noi siamo il team dei bulli
mannai Io sono Billy e io sono Frank è
un'altra giornata di scherzi a scuola sì
non vedo l'ora ma chi sarà il maestro Uh
Eh buongiorno
buongiorno Tutto bene Avete studiato
oggi perché oggi vi interrogo Eh ve lo
dico già interrogazione a tutti
tutto questo sole abbassate Questa
finestra Chiudete le tapparelle per fian
Infatti maestro perché noi vampiri siamo
vicini alla finestra ma il sole bacia i
belli potete scambiarci con quei
pulciosi dei lupi Eh sì Sarebbe meglio
però disinfettate le sedie prima No no
ma perché ci dobbiamo spostare dal
nostro banco all'ultima fila ce lo siamo
meritati di di stare nell'ultima fila i
bulli stanno qui Sì sì avete avete
ragione Scambiatevi con i lupi per
favore Scambiatevi subito vampiri no
maestro non è giusto Ce lo siamo
meritati questo posto infatti Vabbè ci
spostiamo ma gliela faremo pagare va
bene giusto
Ok ciao sono l'emoji di Anita A
proposito di lupi mannari e vampiri nel
mio nuovo libro La città stregata c'è
una
trasformazione in lupo mannaro e un
mistero da risolvere se non ce l'hai
ancora Prendilo subito perché per i
primi a prenderlo ci sarà in regalo un
poster autografato e ricordati di
cliccare mi piace sotto a questo video
Prova a cliccare mi piace entro 3
secondi 3 2 1 tempo scaduto Meno male ci
hanno spostato questa luce scura è
migliore per fare le foto Ah sì qua è
più tetra A proposito guarda cosa ti ho
preso nel cimitero qua vicino
cara quanto ti odio Anche io sei
bruttissima oggi
tesoro
selfie ma insomma silenzio Cos'è questo
bacano stiamo in classe qua Eh oh og
interrogazione ho detto lapide lapide
delle mie brame chi è che devo
interrogare casca proprio al fagiuolo
William e Charlot allag
stupidissimo
mentre la bestia li fissava Al mio tre
scappiamo intesi 1 2 3 strillo Vitale
dandel a gambe immediatamente seguito da
Anita e subito dopo dal lupo mannaro Noi
stiamo leggendo il libro Nel frattempo
la città stregata così se ci chiama
l'interrogazione saremo prontissime E
prenderemo 10 sì Ehi vi faccio uno
spoiler Guardate un'illustrazione del
libro Un lupo mannaro ed è tutto a
colori interrogazione aeva creature
forza cominciamo subito Dai vampiri e
voi appunto siete i vampiri e adesso tu
William Quali sono i punti deboli dei
vampiri
dimmelo Ovviamente la luce del sole
maestro ci ha fatti anche spostare dalla
finestra Purtroppo però perché sennò i
nostri selfie sarebbero
bellissimi Sì sì bravo William Bravo hai
detto uno dei nostri punti deboli inve
c'è signorina Charlotte lei che cosa ha
da aggiungere a riguardo Beh un altro
punto debole dei vampiri è sicuramente
l'ago ma meno male perché puzza troppo
non mi piace Sì sì l'aglio anche Però
devo dire che due spaghetti conago di
Pepero Zigo ogni tanto io me li mangerei
pure
però silenzio non lo dite in giro Siete
stati molto bravi Comunque già perché
oltre che popolari siamo anche
bravissimi a scuola ma vi devo dire che
siete avvantaggiati perché siete dei
vampiri dei vampiri come me subito a
posto andate a posto che dici di
avvisare i nostri follower di questa
stupenda interrogazione andiamo a fare
una diretta dal
banco mi è finuta
un'idea sarà uno scherzo fantastico
Bravo momento selfie
[Musica]
anche con la Rosa scusa Sì
sì Che fastidiosi questi vampiri non
riesco a concentrarmi nel leggere il
libro infatti io lo voglio finire questo
libro lapide lapide delle mie brame chi
è che devo interrogare selfie come non
sento basta In fondo state facendo molto
rumore voi Insomma basta con questi
selfi fateveli vedere che cosa state
facendo guardi quanto siamo
belli questa prospettiva È perfetta E
qua la luce tetra mi risalta gli zigomi
E questa con la
rosa
spettacolare posso vedere le vostre foto
Certo guarda ilara tanto non ci
raggiungerete
mai ma ma non c'è nessuno in questa foto
ti ricordi L'abbiamo letto nel libro I
vampiri non compaiono né nelle foto né
negli specchi è vero ma allora che cosa
ve ne fate di questi selfie potrete solo
vederli voi
vampiri meglio così voi non siete degne
di ammirare la nostra bellezza non siete
importanti quanto
noi continuiamo con la lezione Adesso
andiamo subito alla lavagna scrivo le
formule e voi le copiate scrivete queste
formule
insomma
[Musica]
se più all
18 seconda alla
22esima streghe streghe Anita e e Gim
venite subitissimo non la voglio
risolvere questa formula sarà
facilissimo Noi studiamo sempre Adesso
lo scopriremo subito se siete così brave
come avete detto e se sempre facile come
avete detto Ehi ma non si capisce niente
qua hai mischiato tutte le parole come
facciamo a risolvere questa formula ma
sfi Dalton che per caso c'è scritto
comprendere comprensione c'è scritto
comprensione della formula pericolosa
molto pericolosa di se + 18 ^ quadr alla
22 non si capisce niente Deve scriverlo
meglio Oh va bene Lo scriverò meglio
Allora prendiamo il cancellino e
cancelliamo Ehi ma questo non Cancella
bene sto cancellino Ma questo questo non
è un cancellino è un aglio è un pezzo
d'aglio e su
[Musica]
bellissimo che scherone che l'abbiamo
fatto che puzza che puzza chi è che ha
messo l'aglio Chi Chi è stato Voglio
sapere subito Chi è stato a mettere
l'aglio Mi sento male Mi sento male
l'aglio non può stare così vicino ai
bambini è
pericolosissimo
sento bruciare gli occhi povero maestro
che brutta fine c'è una puzza terribile
sta facendo reazione anche su di noi
quell'alto più Ora cerco un incantesimo
nel libro per farlo
smettere Ecco alteraz ogus vai Aion
ogum Wow ho funzionato abbiamo salvato
la lezione è questo il vantaggio di
essere streghe Noi possiamo usare la
magia Sì sì andate a posto andate a
posto Vi metto un bel 10 per la mela
Grazie copiate queste formule della
lavagna subito certo maestro copiare con
le bacchette è troppo facile un altro
dei nostri vantaggi Esatto Ah non ne ho
voglia di scrivere faccio direttamente
una foto poi passamela così la ricopio
Ah non ci penso neanche a copiare quelle
formule sulla lavagna se neanch'io e non
c'ho neanche il
quaderno che ne dici di fare uno scherzo
a quelle
smorfioso le più brave della classe Oh
sì è sempre un buon momento per fare un
Scherzo dai togliamolo il loro potere
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ok Andate a prendervi il
[Musica]
capello Ma questi guli
le Dove sono le nostre
bacchette Bulli ce le avete
rubate E adesso che abbiamo le bacchette
delle streghe con questi nuovi poteri
saremo inarrestabili E potremmo fare
tutti gli scarti che
vogliamo tanto non le sapete usare
finirete per farvi male o cose del
genere infatti vi conviene restituirle
subito potrebbe finire male per voi col
cavolo che ve le ridiamo intanto senza
queste bacchette non potete farci niente
È vero sei pronto
sì che
[Musica]
brutto come si fa a annullarlo non
funziona più Togliti Togliti a te a te
non
[Applauso]
funziona ma cosa sta
succedendo Siete delle scimie stupidi
così imparate a trasformarci le machette
in
[Musica]
banane siamo rimasti solo noi sì dai
Facciamo scappare le streghe così
vinceremo noi il libro usiamo qualche
filtro questo qui perfetto Ah finalmente
ora che se ne sono andati i lupi Bulli
mannari possiamo leggere in pace Che
pace questo capitolo è bellissimo
Ehi streghe siete in diretta con
l'effetto bruttezza
estrema
osservata Uffa Ma che cosa volete da noi
non vi abbiamo fatto niente perché
vogliamo vincere noi il libro deve
essere nostro vi conviene scappare
immediatamente Ora basta Beccatevi
questo
Ah i telefoni Cos'è
questo Ehi non si possono fare le foto
da qui tutti i miei follower Dove sono
basta andiamo via Che
umiliazione Eh ma dove sono finiti tutti
quanti Beh visto che siete rimasti solo
voi streghe il libro lo Avete vinto voi
sì ora abbiamo tutto e due il libro La
città stregato e se voi ancora non ce
l'avete correte subito a prenderlo e ora
disponibile in libreria e on E ora vi
faciamo Qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
[Musica]
Ciao